I'm painting my twitching high ball and
it's a weird sensation I've just got my
eye a little bit I know nothing about
eyeliner and just the idea of it
terrifies maybe girls wear it to hide
their eye boogers I think girls wear
eyeliner just because it kind of makes
your eyes pop what if I just open my
eyes liner is now a bad time to tell you
I have a phobia of being stabbed in the
eye yeah this looks pretty classic this
is what I am used to seeing on women I'm
supposed to do this yes not gonna be
much classic look after I'm done with
this how do I approach this part close
the eye or do I open it oh God
my hand is shaking oh can you see this
I'm literally crying right now is it
supposed to connect with my eyebrow I'm
gonna look like a raccoon after this oh
man this is not going good
oh-wee this is terrifying man probably
have to make it look like a needle
handlebar eyeliner yeah like I'm all
like I'm dangerous oh man it's like
sticking yep that's it oh and I love
prettiest though BAM I don't know how
you do this ladies I can't
I'm not even to the hard one I'm on the
classic one and I am falling
Bossier under to smoking
next one fishy tale even if I did this
correctly this picture is stupid
who wants parentheses next to their
eyeball this one's like sexy this is the
club look this one is like you're going
out you're trying to get some dick and I
like dick too so hopefully this helps I
can't see I used to watch my mom put on
eyeliner in the mirror and I never
thought I would have to do that same
activity oh no I didn't connect them
somehow why am I having so much trouble
with this how do you guys do this so
easily it's all about relaxation if you
get panicked you know your line up this
is my eyeballs way of saying please
don't do this anymore a girlfriend does
this in the car in the mirror well I
like bumping around in traffic I can't
believe she does this is amazing then I
had the little fish tail down there and
then it turns into blue tears boom
Beth my fish tail this looks terrible
I think I'm done like I don't think I
can improve this I don't like that one
as much and it's probably cuz I'm just a
shitty job I don't feel good anymore
didn't go too well
let's put it that way I look like I got
punched in the face is what happened it
looks so good on the paper it doesn't
make you look sexier though I will say
just like even the way this looks a
hot-ass mess I feel a little bit more
like jazzy